[Applause]
[Music]
so where do you go after Dracula's dead
some fairly interesting places as it
turns out castlevania season 3 this yeah
this is overdue I meant to do this a
while ago it took me longer to get to I
was gonna say get through it didn't take
me a long time to get through it but it
took me longer to get to the season that
I would have liked and then it took me
even longer to sit down and do this and
I actually had reservations about it
just because I felt like I missed the
window it's not a topical anymore
I considered throwing this up in the
break room but now I love this show and
my thoughts on it should have a place of
prominence so let's talk about
castlevania season 3 i had no idea what
this was gonna be going in because
direct Dracula is dead now I know he can
come back I know enough about
Castlevania Lord to know he pretty much
always comes back but I figured they
wouldn't pull the trigger on that right
off and they didn't it gets hinted at oh
and by the way spoilers if you haven't
seen it like and at this point this
review so late that if you cared I hope
you'll have seen it already by now but
it freed it up to go some interesting
places and in some ways this is arguably
bigger in scale and scope then even
season 2 was I think season 2 still my
favorite but it is branching out into
bigger ideas of Hell of the forces at
work because up to this point we really
we really just had everything pivoted
around Dracula up to this point yes
there were other creatures there were
other vampires but basically every
but he was subservient to him they
answered to him or they were subservient
to him he was the central pillar of
pretty much everything supernatural
going on at all well he's gone and a lot
of this stuff still remains because
we've still got Isaac
we still got Hector we've still got more
vampires out there and we've got forces
that we don't really know what the deal
is and it's uh it's really nice to get
to dwell in that space a bit more with
some characters who we already know in
terms of the returning characters I had
the most fun with Sipho like she's just
great I love how much enjoyment she's
getting out of this I mean she plays off
really well from Trevor now Trevor part
of what's interesting to me about this
is that you know Sipho hasn't been doing
this whole hunting demons and the
creatures of the night thing for very
long so for her it's still fun you can
imagine that she is in a place that
Trevor probably was five to ten years
ago but he's done it too long
he seemed too much and you can see some
of the times when he looks at her like
you're gonna end up like me and I'm
sorry never says it but like I had that
read on it at times so I like them and I
like that they just stumble across this
little town this little it means nothing
town that they happen to uncover
something massive that is going to open
a portal to hell and potentially destroy
the freaking world now under normal
circumstances I would call that boy
that's coincidental they're saving the
world again these same people having to
stumble cross it but here it feels more
fitting somehow I think just because it
helps emphasize the idea of the world's
not safe just cuz Dracula's dead so I
roll with it here a bit more than I
might in other places or under other
circumstances I mentioned already Isaac
and Hector
Isaac is
send hating to me I find him to be such
an interesting character like at his
core everything about him like you oh
man there's just something about
somebody who is human but who thinks so
little of humanity and I love that he
gets to have the more philosophical
conversations and moments I love the
conversations he has with the ship
captain those were great I love that an
episode ends on a protracted
conversation that he has with the demon
a monster he created about the life and
the human that that person used to be
and about how they lived their life and
the hell that they went into and what
they are now I love that that
conversation happens and that that
conversation happens not about these
creatures but with one of them oh that
was cool
I think that's sort of the odd thing for
me the big highlight of season two was
the assault on the castle and the all
the fights in the combat in the fight
with Dracula it was the action that that
the entire season the entire show up to
that point of it building to the
highlights for me here were actually
conversations they were conversations
that Isaac had with the captain that he
had with that creature that he made that
he has with the witch the conversations
that Trevor and Sipho have with the
judge or they have with Saint Germain
Bill Nighy yes the win always those
conversations were really the highlight
for me here we does not say the action
isn't still good but the action has
already been taken up to 11 so it's hard
to top so I like that there's this shift
for these sorts of things for me the
conversations felt like they had more
weight and depth to them than they did
in a lot of the earlier seasons that's
not to say there was no weight behind
conversations in the earlier seasons
just that they felt like they were
letting us know about the characters and
this time it feels more like it's
letting us know about this entire world
and this entire philosophy that's
driving this piece of art or in some
cases of the contrasting philosophies
depending on what characters were
dealing with so I enjoyed that quite a
bit
hi so that was good stuff new characters
I mentioned saint-germain and Bill Nighy
he's always good for this there's the
judge who's also pretty good voiced by
Jason Isaak fun side note um my partner
Liz has a massive crush on Jason Isaacs
and she came in on me watching an
episode and you remember the judge he's
bald he's he's just a guy but you know
she sees him and she's like he seems
kind of hot and I'm like he's voiced by
jason isaacson he goes that's why she
didn't even know she just heard she
didn't even recognize the voice but her
immediate thought is he's hot but jason
isaacs does a good job of bringing the
weight and the gravity through his voice
did that capture the character needs
because he needs to be a credible
authority so that works very well the
four vampire sisters they were they were
fun
Lenore obviously gets to be the
highlight and that that was well
executed even though it was blatantly
obvious where it was going to go and how
it was going to end like from the
beginning you knew she was going to
break him and as the whole thing went on
you saw how she was going to break him
which lends a certain amount of tragedy
to Hector it does give it that sort of
oh god dude you're not really gonna oh
there he goes and it was well executed
but the fact that it was the storyline
that had the clearest end point I knew
exactly where that was going
made it a little bit less interesting
even though it was still well executed
for what it was I really did enjoy the
two of them I forget the names of some
of the other vampire sisters and that
but I loved the two who are debating
whether or not Carmilla has
plans or schemes and then neighbors and
my sisters we have a scheme ah they were
fun I enjoy them and I'm gonna be just
see where things go with them in a
future season I like that they didn't
bring back Dracula in this story proper
but they make it clear oh look there he
is on the other side of a hell portal
and he's willing to come back from the
look of it so that was cool I like that
I kind of hoped that if he does come
back it's not in season 4 which has
already been confirmed thankfully or at
least that's not the bulk of it I still
want to deal with the characters that we
have and how things are gonna pan out
there oh also the climax with Isaac now
in some ways that was a little bit weird
because we have no investment in this
magician who has just enslaved all these
people because we haven't seen him we
don't know him but at the same time that
confrontation was cool and creepy and
they had freaking legion ah ha ha as
someone who has played and loves some
Castlevania games but has not played all
of them I have really enjoyed what I
have recognized things from the games
that I've played and seeing Legion that
big massive ball of bodies oh that bad
mmm right a little shriveled walnut I
have instead of a heart oh that got me
right there that was good but you know
it there there isn't I don't know for a
second I was about to say there isn't as
much emotional weight in that
confrontation as there should be except
that Isaac's carrying a lot of weight
completely on his own because he's kind
of battling his own path and his own
intentions trying to figure out if he's
actually gonna go through with what he
said he wanted to do and how committed
he is to it so he is kind of pulling the
emotional weight on his own it would
have been nice if there could have been
more investment in who he was fighting
if there's gonna be a weak element of
this particular season I
it's gonna be Alucard I think narrative
Li what is happening with Alucard is not
uninteresting but it is the least
interesting thing going on this season
and it feels very much like a
placeholder plot the entire thing with
these people who want to know how to
kill vampires better coming for
friending betraying him it it ultimately
leaves him more or less back where he
started
only more so like in a deeper funk than
when we saw him but effectively in the
same place but the fact that he has some
deeper probably means something he's
probably gonna be relevant but this
really did feel like something of we're
gonna need him next season we can't lose
track of him here's what he's been doing
it didn't really feel like it built too
much of anything it didn't really feel
like it told us all that much knew about
Alucard or even changed him
significantly it kind of reaffirmed
certain things that maybe he was on the
fence about but it didn't seem to have
massively altered him at least not as
we've seen yet maybe the fallout from
this will be more clear in the following
season but right now self-named within
season 3 is just kind of a thing that
happened maybe part of it was I just
didn't fully connect with those
characters either so that the sense of
betrayal didn't hit me as hard but I
mean like I didn't call it from the
beginning but I did call it as soon as
they showed up in his bedroom I'm like
oh no this is gonna go badly which bit
of a running thing here with some of the
characters that sex leads to very bad
things although I guess - Trevor seemed
to have a fairly functional relationship
as far as that goes I love the aesthetic
of this thing I love the look of the
monsters I love the feel the atmosphere
of the vibe
I love how serious it takes itself but
it has characters who aren't above
cracking a joke I love its use of
swearing to be honest it some might call
it superfluous but I feel like the
sentences and the points at which
characters choose to swear are like yeah
you needed to emphasize that point we
an f-bomb that works I feel like the
choice of places to swear is a little
bit more carefully selected than it
usually is in these kinds of things
overall castlevania season 3 I like it
I'm here for it season 2 still the best
but I want more and I'm glad that season
before it got confirmed so castlevania
season 3 have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something on down
in the comments let's talk about it
whole bunch of stuff to do as well like
subscribe support me on patreon and
that's immensely helpful plus odd links
other things that I do or take part in
or whatever that you can click on but
you also don't have to because at the
end of the day you are the council I
just run the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]